our next topic is convolution
uh it's something you may have seen in
other courses as well or we'll see in
other courses as well for example it
comes up in probability
um it comes up in signal processing
a bunch of areas so it's actually
something very good to know about
so and this is i should say this is
completely standard uh mathematical
notation
so uh and it comes up in lots and lots
of different areas
okay so if you have an uh an n vector a
and an m vector b the convolution and
it's denoted with this
star uh of course the star hints that
it's some kind of a multiplication
that's true uh it is a kind of a
multiplication
so um this is denoted so you say
a convolved with b is what c is
and it's an n plus m minus one vector
and its entries are given by
uh sums of products of an entry from a
and an entry from b now which which
entries
uh that's complicated it's given by this
kind of scary looking formula here
but what it is is it's it's all the
products ai and bj
where i plus j adds up to k plus one
so let's take a look at an example let's
do this with n equals four and m equals
three so
a is a four vector and b is a 3 vector
then we form c we're going to simply
form c
equals a convolved with b
and now we'll tell you what the entries
of c are and
we're just using this formula here but i
think you'll see a pattern here
so c1 is going to be the product of
every ai
and bj where i plus j adds up to two
well the only choice there is they're
both one so you get c one is a one b one
which notice is like a product um c two
is all of the products of a i and b j
for which i plus j adds up to three and
there's two ways to do that there's one
plus two and there's two plus one and
there you go these are the two entries
it's a one
b two plus a two b one
uh c three that's going to be all the
ways
it's it's the product it's the sum of
the products of all
of the entries of eights of a i b j
where i plus
j adds up to four and the ways to do
that are one three
two two and three one okay and so on
okay so at this point you might be
saying
like well this is crazy this is
complicated it is complicated um but in
fact
you'll get used to it and it'll actually
have a meaning for you and depending on
what field you're in
it may end up being a well a very
important part of your life is
convolution
okay so here's a specific example if i
just take the convolution of these
two vectors here i i get this vector
here and we can at least audit the size
right so here
m and n are both three and so you should
get something that is
uh three uh it's it's uh three plus
three
minus one so you should get a five
vector and indeed that's that's exactly
what we get
i'm not going to audit it uh i there
might be an
error in that anyway but but my
suspicion is it's right
uh and that this is actually what the
convolution of that is right so
at this point by the way you should have
absolutely no idea why anyone should
care about this or why would
you okay fine so here's really here's
where it comes up this is a very
important uh
idea it's essentially polynomial
multiplication and be honest it's the
way i think about it i only think about
this polynomial multiplication
so let me explain so suppose the
n vector a represents the coefficients
of a polynomial this way
so a1 is the zeroth order coefficient a2
is the x to the one coefficient right
and so on up to a
n which is the x to the n minus one
coefficient
okay and the same for b except b only
goes up to
the x to the m minus one coefficient so
so the vectors a and b
represent the coefficients of a
polynomial well
it turns out if i call this polynomial p
of x and that's q of x and i take the
product now the product of two
polynomials is a polynomial also
and in fact it is one of a degree up to
m plus n minus one m uh n
plus m minus one and its coefficients
are precisely
the convolution like that um so
uh if we were to go back and see that
here it says that another way to get
these coefficients is
actually uh to multiply two polynomials
together and collect the coefficients
and the coefficients give you the
entries of the convolution so for
example
it would be a 1 plus a 2
x plus a 3 x
squared plus a 4 x cubed and we would
multiply that by
b 1 plus b b2 x plus b3
x squared right and if i multiply these
two polynomials
together i multiply everything out
and i collect the terms and i would get
things like for example the constant
term
when i multiply this polynomial by this
polynomial
well the only way to get the constant
term is by multiplying a1 and b1
oh hey look at that that's what c1 is
now how do you get the x term
the linear term when i multiply this
polynomial by this one
well the only way to do that is the
constant times the linear part
plus the linear part here times the
constant so that's a1
times b2 plus a2 times b1
and that is exactly c2 and so on so so
basically what convolution is
is it tells you how the coefficients
it gives you the coefficients of the
product polynomial
okay so that's the idea now once you
have that interpretation
a lot of things come for free that would
otherwise be well kind of a pain
to show yourself so for example it turns
out
that the uh the convolution of a and b
is the same as convolution of b and a
so or you would say it is commutative
commutative means you can carry out an
operation in either order and you get
the same thing
so that's what that's what this tells
you why is the answer is that when i
multiply the polynomial p of x times q
of x
i get the same thing as multiplying the
polynomial q of x times b of x
so it's got to be the same
here's one it is associative if i
take the convolution of a and b and then
convolve that with c
turns out that's exactly the same as
convolving b and c
first and then convolving that with a
convolving is the verb for convolution
right okay
okay so that's again that comes just
from polynomials you're just multiplying
three polynomials together and you're
collecting the coefficients
in like powers of x and then the result
is what you get okay it also tells you
this it says that the convolution of two
vectors is zero
only if one of them is zero okay so um
that's the idea oh i should also say if
if the two
if if the two vectors are one vectors
right like their
m n equals m equals one then convolution
is just ordinary multiplication
it's nothing but multiplying two two
numbers together
so in that sense you can think of
convolution as a
generalization of multiplication
okay now we can represent convolution
using matrix vector
product okay so let's see how that works
suppose c is is a
convolved with b i can write that
as a matrix t of b
times a so uh that's how that works
and for example this is this is an
example for a particular size of b
which is b is three and a is four so
it's following the example
uh from uh here so the these these
dimensions
okay but for that that example a t of b
looks like this and you can just check
that if i multiply this
by a 1 a 2
a 3 a4 if i multiply this matrix
here by this vector what i will get
that's no longer t of b
but this is going to tell me it's going
to give me the convolution and
i'll just work out a couple of things
like the first row is
going to be the first one is going to be
a1 b1
which is correct okay and the next one
is i'm going to go across here
and down here and i'm going to get b2
a1 plus b1
a2 right and i i keep going down
and you'll see that i'm getting the
convolution so that's that's a
now the matrix t of b is super
interesting it's called a topless matrix
or tuplets matrix
that's named after a mathematician named
triplets um
and it's a super interesting matrix if
you take a look at it
it's so on the these are the when you
look at
these are called the diagonals of a
matrix right they're
they're all the entries where um
you know i plus uh i i might i i
i minus j is equal to some number right
like
when they're equal that's that that that
is called the diagonal
right but these are these are the
diagonals and what you see is that this
is the templates matrix
is constant on the diagonals that's the
right way to say it so
in other words if you're if you have a
triplets matrix and you know what the
value is at one point then it's got to
be the same
all up and down that diagonal so that's
it so
these come up in a lot of areas but what
this says is another way to say if you
connect all these things is you're
saying that
to multiply a polynomial if you
represent a polynomial
by a vector of its coefficients and it
says if you multiply by another
polynomial
you get of course another polynomial and
its coefficients are given by a matrix
times the original vector and that
matrix is this tuplets matrix
t of b okay so that's the idea
okay now i'll just mention a few quick
cases where convolution and therefore
triplets matrices
come up so one very common thing
is um is in time series so i think of x
representing a time series so x1 is the
first sample it's a number
x2 is the second sample x3 and it could
be anything you like it could be the
temperature and 10 minute intervals it
could be the price
of something doesn't matter what it is
right it's just
it's just a time series okay now
if i do a convolution with uh
a where a is this vector it's one third
one third one third
then it turns out what you get is y k is
is this and it's actually beautiful what
it is is it is a sum
so each y k is a is an average
of a little window of three different
x's
okay and so uh people call that a three
period moving average
and it's used of course what it does is
it smooths out a time
series so over here here's a time series
uh
i don't know what it is it doesn't
matter and here it is
i have now convolved it with uh
a which is one third one third one third
and you get
kind of something that has the same
shape uh but it has um
it but it's smoother and it's smoother
because you're sort of averaging stuff
so if it kind of jumps up and jumps down
that gets smoothed out a little bit by
the averaging
okay so it's a smoothing very very
common
uh there's a very common operation to
carry out on a time series
just so that your eye is not you know
whatever um
distracted by all the wiggles right so
it would be very common in
economics or finance to quote like a
five-day
a five-day you know moving average is
what this would be called
so that's an example okay so
so it comes up a lot in uh in time
series this is one example
now it also comes out in uh as an
interpretation of an input output system
and let me explain what that means so we
think of
u that's actually one of the traditional
names used towards foreign input
so and it's a time series and then
the vector y also represents a time
series but we think of u as an input
and y is an output i could give you lots
of examples of this
but u could be the
power that we apply to a heater
and y could be the temperature rise
of let's say whatever i'm heating um and
let's say this is sampled on every you
know five minute intervals or one minute
intervals it really doesn't matter
right then um then that's the idea that
would be an example and by the way
such as such systems i mean depends on
what it is of course but
would generally be described precisely
by convolution right so
it says uh so you think of you
as as what goes in and why is the result
um
and so what when it turns out that the
the so-called output
um is is simply a convolution of the
input with something
um one of the traditional names is h uh
it's called a convolution model
so it means that i i don't know what
this thing well okay
what it says it's a very specific i'm
saying what this what the way you relate
the input to the output is
it's via convolution and h is called
lots of different things it's called the
system
impulse response uh that would be in
mechanical engineering and electrical
engineering for example
it would have other names in statistics
it comes up as well
and it's called the kernel in
mathematics that would be a very common
thing you might heard it'd be the
convolution kernel
you would hear that and if you hear that
um so it's just an impulse response is
actually a little bit of a dialect
that's not standard
like if you walk into a math department
and say oh the impulse response is this
they'll say
what is that right but if you say sorry
i meant to say convolution kernel
they'll say oh
cool why didn't you say so okay and what
it says
is this if we write out what it means it
it looks like this and it's a it's a
it's a kind of a scary equation but
let's take a look at it
it says that the the i output
is equal to it's a sum um
over the inputs here um multiplied by h
j now u minus j plus one is something
if you think of i as now then u
minus j plus 1 is something like you
know
j minus 1 steps ago that's what it means
and it says you multiply that by h j and
so what it says is
the output now is a linear combination
of previous inputs with the coefficients
given by h
j okay so that's the idea and so in fact
you can even interpret
j as literally the number of periods ago
that's what it means because it tells
you your current output
how does it depend on the input let's
say three samples before
and that would be something like h3 okay
so that's what it says um and here you
can interpret h3 as the
as the factor by which the current
output depends on what the input was two
time steps before
two times just because the first one
tells you how it depends on now and then
previous than previous previous and that
would give you h3
so that's the and input output systems
come up
throughout actually all of science and
engineering i mean it's just it's
absolutely ubiquitous right it could be
things like
you know the rainfall in a region that
could be you
and y could be the height of a river
above
some normal height that would be given
by convolution
um in uh thermal systems dynamical
mechanical systems would many mechanical
systems would work this way
so it would just be this is an extremely
common
uh model of systems
you